i didn't know whether or not i was going
to go there i'm going to go there i
wrote it last night at pft i mean racism
is racist you either stand up against
all forms of it or you don't one of the
nfl's 32 franchises has a name that is
racist by definition change the channel
washington fans i don't care your name
is racist by definition
what an opportunity to seize on it in
this moment and say we're against all
forms of racism not just racism against
african-americans we're against racism
of all types of all forms against all
people including the indigenous
americans who were here before we came
over from europe and took over
so this is the moment this is the time
the right thing to do to send a message
to everyone about the evils of racism is
to take this term that over the passage
of time has become a textbook slur
and abandon it you want to show strength
daniel snyder in the city where there
are real questions about how much
strength the chief occupant of the most
significant structure there is showing
in this moment that's a way to show
strength that's a way to show courage
that's a way to show leadership that's a
way to inspire change
let's see if there's any conversation
about that happening other than people
telling me to shut my big fat mouth
yeah well you know normally i'd like you
to like to tell you to shut your big fat
mouth but you're right on this one and
there's no denying it all right you do
got a big fat mouth i agree with a lot
of people out there but uh i'm with you
i mean come on you're right this is the
right time to do it start showing people
that hey we can make a change and we're
going to do something for the better and
hey let's let's all join the fight and
you know
and and try to find some good in this uh
you know and the bottom line is
my this is how my dad broke it down to
me when this first became a subject he
goes christopher would you go up on the
would you go on the street and go and
see a native american and say hey
[ __ ] how you doing no i would not of
course not that's ridiculous that's
that's i mean that's the point so if
you're not willing to do that that tells
you there's a problem with the word you
know and and
so yes i'm with you there and you know
back to like what we were talking about
with like the call to action and you
know i don't want to sound insensitive
in the nfl because i know they're doing
a lot of things mike uh behind the
scenes to help this this cause in this
issue but you got to do something too
that you know rallies the masses and to
me like the best example right now and
something where i would love the nfl to
see it i don't know if you saw this mike
but like the nike don't do it thing that
they released through you know social
media and all that that has like 300
million views and all that type of stuff
those are powerful words and statements
that people can get behind and it
spreads through social media to where
people who may be racist or on the fence
or whatever it may be they start to read
those things and and then they read the
comments underneath it and it stirs you
know thought and and and moving forward
as a society so that's something i would
like to the nfl to see them do that
that's what i was referring to as far as
something tangible
there are many ways that this moment can
be seized upon by our most prominent
institutions private institutions that
have a very public existence like sports
leagues that's that's why sports leagues
are so important in america that's why
they get regulated from time to time by
the federal government by congress is
interested in what they're doing they
are a huge part of our shared public
existence right when when a pandemic
strikes one of the first concerns is
what happens to our sports
right that's right up there with what
happens to ourselves what happens to our
sports it's a key part of our life it's
why you and i have jobs people care
about this stuff so when there is a
moment like this
and you have the resources when you have
the voice when you have the platform
you got to use it
and whether it is coming up with
effective social media strategies to
spread the message that the time for
racism is over whether it is changing a
name that
that should have been changed several
years ago and that that could be changed
right now and send one of the most
powerful messages that ever has come
from the national football league at a
time of crisis and it would inspire
others to search their hearts and search
their souls for things they can do to be
part of the solution
look i i think it's a pipe dream i think
the chances of it happening are
incredibly slim
uh but uh you want to wait you want a
way to to to
to provide a shining example that you
are part of the solution national
football league you get to daniel snyder
today and you say
now is the time to change this name and
issue a statement with it saying
i was wrong i was blind to the impact of
this word and in this moment my eyes are
open
and this is what i'm doing and think of
how much good chris
could come from from a gesture like that
it may hurt the bottom line in the short
term right it might but think of how
much good think of how much good could
come from that you know it might it
might hurt the bottom line in the short
time but i doubt it i think you know you
know in general
there's going to be more people and more
people that'll gravitate to the
washington team and jump on the
bandwagon if they do make a change like
that so uh yeah it might hurt it just at
first but i think all in all
you know it could be something good for
the bottom line and of course it can
bring a lot of good to our country and
the cause and everything like that so
i'm with you mike well said
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports